Okay, we're swapped now.
We're swapped.
I couldn't find the screen.
You baited?
You baited.
I couldn't find the screen!
She's baiting again.
Anyway, welcome.
We're TSM.
Hey guys, new TSM team here.
New TSM team.
They just signed us up, guys.
Cause like last time TSM got like 17th place.
So then they called us up to replace them.
Yeah.
Killed them the boot.
got the mood this is how it's gonna be now we're gonna go to
lgs hell yeah we got like we're gonna go to world cup world
yeah that's what it's called world cup that's what they call
it yeah yeah let's go world cup yeah i'm gonna be goalkeeper
oh my god guys guys okay So our PR is going to carry us and
he's going to be on bloodhound No, I'm not going to be
bloodhound I'm probably going to play wraith So we can win
What do we play then?
We need a We need a bloodhound Okay, I can play bloodhound
How about we play lifeline bloodhound?
Oh shit We're going European comp?
And right?
Yeah, so we can one live, two port and three sea Okay, I'll
be lifeline i'll be like that yeah yeah yeah dude it's gonna
be our controller player
it's just scrims it's not even the real tournament yeah
scrims that we didn't even know where we landed two two
minutes before you started you were the one that gave me the
landing spot you asked me to give you landing spots and then
you landing spots are not enough.
You need to give me 10 for each map.
I wasn't the one that made the rules for this.
They were like, you have to list like 10.
Okay, they wanted more.
I like shortened it because I was like, I'm not fucking
asking.
I'm not fucking asking RPR for 10 landing spots.
It was like eight.
I don't even know 10 landing spots on the map.
Give me top five.
You know what they asked for me?
They said give us eight.
And I was like, I'm just going to give them five.
I was like, there's no way.
I barely know five.
Remember when you asked me I was that oh shit how like what
the fuck is this?
They wanted okay to be fair They also wanted me to be there
at 10 a.m.
To like see who's gonna get the landing spots But I was like
I don't want to wake up at 10 man.
I don't I don't Yeah I don't even wake up for LGS about
they're like okay you can if you're busy Okay, but to be
fair they're like it to everybody is like oh you can't make
it to 10 a.m.
Just let us know in advance And I was like, oh, thank God.
I don't have to wake up at 10 in the morning to figure out
where the fuck we're landing.
Okay, how are we the laziest team in the fucking lobby?
But we got the best landing spot.
This doesn't make any sense.
We're just that lucky.
We got siphon and barometer.
Okay, if we get fucking absolutely fucked over with the best
landing spots, this is our PR's fault.
How is it like?
Okay, listen because you're the one that chose those landing
spots You chose these landing spots.
I gave us the best possible conditions.
I gave us the best possible conditions to win Yeah, but if
we don't win then it's IGL's fault Deep does IGLing no you
said IGL can never be a bloodhound.
Yeah, she can't be she's on bloodhound I'm tired of being
wrong.
I don't want to be voted all the time Yeah, that's why you
are being right Someone else just take the fault for one.
Well, then someone else be IGL.
Not me.
You have to be IGL because you're AOGS champion.
Yeah, you're AOGS champion.
Exactly.
Oh, no.
I was cursed with such a high IQ.
Holy shit.
Such an high IQ, but yeah, you don't win this scrim.
I don't know.
I am not at fault for my teammates' actions.
is the igl's fault that is not how this is 100 how it works
i've seen competitive apex on reddit that's exactly how it
works okay reddit hates me by the way they think i do
nothing for my team
but they're they're but but they're right they're normies
normies are always right yeah that's like me watching uh
football for once a week uh for the next three years and
being like You know, he should have went left.
And then he should have kicked the ball to the right.
And then he's right.
And he's right.
You're right.
Listen, listen, it's simple.
Apex is simple.
Kill everyone, win the game.
But what if you don't kill everyone?
Ditto, can you kill everybody?
Then you lose.
Maybe if Afya don't die first.
Ditto, what is your stream title?
Ditto, Ditto.
Ditto!
Oh, my!
SciShow, my!
Maji-roll!
Ah!
Don't worry!
It's okay, it's okay!
We don't have life.
Okay, I guess I'm on Bloodhound, I guess.
Okay, also Sound Guy, I turned down RPR and turned up Ditto.
Let me know if it's better now.
How the fuck is this my fault?
Please tell me.
This is your fault, because you're the one that yelled at
Ditto!
Not me!
You have to tell me to shoot the Kaiko, okay?
She is so I might have to mute the both of you guys for this
tournament so we can win
They knew they knew we picked the wrong characters They
ended it for us Sign up for this is all you said yes.
I was like you said you said yes Yeah, that was the first
mistake number one
don't worry we'll be fine we'll be okay you see chat doesn't
know what tsm stands for it's tsm we got signed guys we're
on tsm now can chat guess what tsm stands for because our
tsm is a little bit different than team so we're copyright
free we're like tsm on wish
it's okay guys i believe in us to get top five because
there's like you know there's like not even a full fucking
roster here dude i was built for this shit bullying vtubers
and customs that's my that's my whole fucking career is what
i do yeah because you couldn't bully pro players anymore i
literally want champs like what are you You have to bully
VTubers to feel good about yourself.
Yeah.
Yeah, fuck them VTubers.
It's fucked up.
Fuck them.
Okay, and you bring Ditto up a little bit more on Discord.
Now you're at 190 for me.
TSM stands for Team So Mad.
Because that's what I'm going to be on a break in this
session.
Team so mad.
so mad that's us who's gonna be mad yeah we're gonna be
we're gonna titito and i're gonna have fun yeah yeah because
we're i'm here to have fun because we're all good friends
everybody yes yeah this is just friendship and positivity
pma you always need that one guy in the group that you piss
off because it's funny i and i maintain my positive mental
attitude through this pma Yay!
PMA!
Keep it up!
Yay!
See?
He loves it here, guys.
He loves it here.
He can see that.
Where's the gun?
You can see he's a little M because he likes it.
You went too far.
There's a line you cannot cross.
And you crossed it.
What do you mean?
What's the line?
If there was a line, you would have said no.
Listen, I'm tired of his slander.
If there was a line, you would have said, you wouldn't even
be here.
Like, I can't take this shit no more.
I'm actually going to become Menhara.
This is crazy.
Wait, you're not already?
I'm on my way.
I'm not fucking Sundhara.
Is he a, Ditto, is he a Menhara?
you know yeah i'm all my way yeah me too i think so too if i
am manhira then you reach the fucking he's he invented
manhira he said the duties what manhira and he said he like
manhira okay i said a little bit of manhira is okay me and
you reese both agree that 30 manhira is okay wait what's
what is considered 30 how would you know when somebody's 30
manhira okay but like what what it is a 30 yeah how can you
tell somebody's a 30 manhara whatever there's like 31 well
okay so here's the scale if they're at 100 then you're going
to die if they're at 30 you're just gonna have a little bit
of like uh like a little bit of a little bit of a thrill
action in your life like every now and then what's a thrill
like what's the oh you're still a little scared for your
life every now and then you know like action you know you
speak from experience like you've had the 30 manhara okay
but like what tips it over the edge what makes it a 31
manhara versus a 30 wait but then getting stabbed but a
hundred percent you die so like not every stabbing would
equals in death you know that okay how yeah how can you know
who you get stabbed in your leg well you can have blood just
pour out what infection but you what if you get like what if
it's like a rusty knife but that's then that's that's over
30 then that's too far but like you didn't know you don't
like what if it was an accident you know like she was just
going over to clean the knife because it was getting rusty
she was going to unrest it she tripped and then she tripped
but that's not mehira that's an accident manhara is like
yeah but the manhara part is that she's carrying a rusty
knife around she was gonna go clean it though yeah but the
the same part was to just throw it away so she threw it into
me oh hey okay we got where we land okay i'll go i'm sure
chat agrees with me and that's all i need wait is that
siphon okay this is siphon i've it's been a while guys uh
listen i'm gonna go i'm gonna go far uh i'm gonna go far i'm
gonna go all the way or are you going all the way away from
us i'll be just gonna die no one's gonna contest us ditto he
hates us he doesn't want to be near us he doesn't want to be
near us he hates us okay i see that's sad yeah do you think
we're ben hara's i think you guys are yandere that's
who yonder is yonder yeah how how what is it like you know
how like no i don't if i knew i wouldn't ask stop the cap
oh man oh boy oh what i think they and i are perfectly
normal girls yeah yeah yeah absolutely yeah we're so normal
right ditto yeah nothing but normal yeah normal i think
you're the freak here if i make a poll right now people
always think you're the freak no i think chad probably
agrees with me like they they probably say that 30 30
menhara is an adequate amount of menhara we're not talking
about that i'm talking about pull of whether or not you're
more menhara than us oh no chad knows i'm the only sane
person in this you want bet how much i don't have money Like
you're gonna make a poor streamer.
You're gonna steal money from a poor streamer.
Yes To prove a boy No, I'm not a psychopath.
I just proved my I'm here to prove a point that you are
wrong Dang, I am correctness you are correctness.
Okay I need I am Correctness I'm gonna need that
Nice what's your like your scope?
i don't know igl what is the zone i mean we have the we can
have a people's ring here okay yeah we don't we okay we do i
i will scan the yeah scan go go go go hit the bacon hit the
bacon oh we all have purple this is not very cash money igl
why can't you find better guns igl I'm going to drop this
Mozambique and take the Sentinel and bully this entire lobby
okay what are you gonna die I don't die no this happened to
me okay what happened in the last ALGS you're a part of and
then I died okay where do we go it wasn't we need we need
old charger we need the army you take the evil evo and then
he goes zone okay where is zone and now take this evo oh
okay okay okay i'm gonna head to rpr you press the m on your
on your on your uh the fucking keyboard yeah you press m and
you open map and there's a big circle and we go in the
middle of the big circle okay yeah that's how it works i
mean a real ice show would know exactly where the end zone
is but no one can read the no jesus on this planet zero can
no he can't he's just lying you can he always gets the end
zone correct yeah i'll drink two of course he does no he
gets it right on ring one he's like a saban not okay well
zero's cheating like what do you want from me i don't cheat
i play fair and square fair and square yeah that's why you
just pull your vtubers now yeah exactly
you hear here folks our pr says zero is cheating he is do i
do i get the revive or the reduced tactical rpr revive okay
if we go down we go up 20 faster all right and then the next
one you should probably get the package so we get good stuff
someone's aiming at me i'm about to move Why should we go
next?
Well, I got shot at.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
70 balloon catalyst.
Where the fuck are they going, huh?
Okay, I'm going to port us up the hill.
Okay, we'll wait.
Are they looking at us?
Yes, they are, but their efforts are useless.
Whoa.
I got the port.
I didn't die, guys.
I only have one bat.
Wait, did it not near the port?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Who do they think they are?
I don't know.
I got sand on my hands.
Did they kill us?
We're fucked.
I did more damage with them than they did to us.
Let's go.
I lost my only bat.
Oh, there's a team on the right.
There's a team on the right.
Team on the right.
Oh, yeah.
Close, close.
Flash, flash, flash.
Nice.
I know one.
Bangalore 70.
Nice.
Push this.
Push left.
Push left together.
Just keep pushing downhill.
Keep pushing downhill.
Okay, okay.
I'm walking up there.
Because they're going to get sandwiched.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
And honestly, kill these motherfuckers.
Who the fuck do they think they are?
Yeah, who are they?
Yeah, yeah, kill the rest of these motherfuckers.
Yeah!
Yeah, fuck this Bangalore.
Yeah, we're TSM!
He's low, he's low, he's low, he's low, he's low.
Get him, dude!
Get him!
Yeah!
Yeah, fuck him up!
Motherfuckers!
Yeah, do a finisher!
Do a finisher, do a finisher, do a finisher, do a finisher!
Do a finisher, do a do it!
I'ma rip, I'ma rip the whole thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're gonna watch.
We're gonna watch.
Fuck VTubers.
Yeah, fuck VTubers.
What are you doing in this VTuber apex tournament?
Oh, hey, I need it.
Oh, my God, they got juice.
I want energy and energy armor.
I got nothing here.
I'll give you 60.
Okay, I need to.
And I switch to bloodline.
I didn't get Q.
Someone's looking at us.
I don't know.
Maybe a teammate.
Where are we going, by the way?
I don't know, but I'm finishing the kill.
There's a kill to finish.
Oh, there he is.
Yeah, okay.
Let's go along guys.
Now we gotta move.
It is, oh my god, this zone is ass.
Oh, I have a care package that could call.
Should I call it or wait until I get purple?
No, let's get to like a better spot.
There's a lot of motherfuckers around us.
Yeah.
And I'm not vibing with that.
Oh, we got scanned on Epi.
Yeah, then I don't think those guys are gonna fuck with us.
Yeah, they know who we are.
No, I mean, we're not even in their trajectory.
Yeah, no, no, they know who we are.
Yeah, they have walls.
They can see our names.
I think this is like...
Oh, fuck.
This is this zone right here.
Absolute asshole of a zone.
I have Rita player.
If we want to use it.
Honestly, yeah, I don't want to walk.
Right here?
Right here.
Guys, he's AFK.
Shoot him.
It was all a bait.
I knew the streams that I think
Wait, none of you guys have redeploy I have mobile respawns
so we can get Detop when she dies Who's gonna die first?
I have for you too Yeah, yeah You're both family You got me
covered I got you covered That's so good Wait, what about
me?
You're good Don't die You don't die, don't die, don't die
Okay, you're right I believe in you Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
See, somebody believes in me Why do I never die?
Wait, I try it.
When do I use my package?
I chill.
I'll just use it here.
We're cool.
We're cool here.
Okay.
I'm gonna charge my Sentinel.
Now the real game has started.
All right.
I'm about to Krayber everyone.
Ooh, sniper bag.
This was juice.
Oh, this is a juice package.
All right, let's get to Joan.
All right, we're right behind you.
If I read this wrong, it's Zero's fault.
It's Zero, why it's in Zero's fault.
I watch him for zone predictions.
You watch him for zone.
Yeah.
So if this is wrong, this is his fault.
Just saying.
Yeah, it's you.
Oh my god.
Dido just fucking going all the battery.
People here.
You made it?
I have two.
Let's get in this building.
We want this building.
I will give you two.
Nobody.
Because they can't read zones.
Yeah.
You can't read zones like our player zero.
I think God zero is here for us.
yep he's such a good guy man we love dz i cracked that
catalyst i'm gonna bully that team until they have no more
meds all right wait i need to turn up ditto more on my
discord give me a sec i'm afk i cracked too she's lying on
discord wait there's people here on me wait how are they
purple they're cheating wait they have purple and we don't
why are you almost dead explain yourself because i got shot
by three fucking people i explained okay valid like oh why
would you get shot by three people oh did how did you get
shot at huh yeah exactly why is that motherfucker shooting
at me hello oh nice see there's like extra oh nice there's a
barrel sentinel was such a good choice you can bully
everyone now yeah yeah keep picking see what happens your
head why are you tap strafing bro he wants to show people
his movement i just hit you on the head you're dumbass head
why are you walking here i want to be part of the
my bull is part of your head i want to contribute to society
oh my god he's flesh oh yeah that guy got doink i wish you
can like farm armories again wait wait rp you should try and
get the get that for us yeah yeah i mean i could port for it
but i could i mean who's gonna kill yeah who's gonna kill
you that guy might
motherfucker okay i'm not gonna peek anymore they have four
shields i'm about to go crazy but you're actually going for
it you're throwing of course i am like what you're fucking
what do you mean i'm throwing my i choose throwing only one
there my oh shit purple i knew that was a good you're
welcome i told you to use that idea yeah yeah yeah whatever
you literally
what's your proof can that guy stop looking at me keeps
giving me those alerts you be i don't care i'm being aimed
at what are you looking here man okay i have three shield
cells left guys what the are you doing i want to no more
peeking for you but i want to peek it's not fair they're
shooting at me it's not fair oh wait what's this package
okay um package Oh, who wants that?
I do.
I want it.
Where's our portal?
It's outside our building.
You can just jump for this one.
But what if I die?
You're not going to die.
There's no one there.
You're chilling.
But what if I die?
You trust me.
There is going to be no death involved.
All right.
I'm going to throw my prowler.
I'm going for it.
Holy shit.
Your prowler was true.
Yeah, it was.
Okay, I'm going for it.
There's going to be no death involved unless you die.
I'm going for it.
I got a dead slide.
Okay, we're going to go there now.
Why is this guy looking at me?
I have a purple barrel stabilizer.
Does anyone want it?
No, I'm just going to go there and secure this spot.
Here's the...
Oh, I got the...
next lifeline package contains and we're going to keep we're
going to keep going forward what do you mean knock one you
crack someone stop knocking people i i thirsted him she
keeps knocking people like what the next spot we're going to
the next spot if you're showing him here guys i have yeah
it's my fault why did you thirst him he got revived i'm
getting pushed I'm getting pushed.
Wait, wait.
Come back in.
Come back to our side.
I almost killed two of them.
Come back.
I have a Phoenix kit for you.
We need to stop these motherfuckers.
We're taking our house.
We got to kill these motherfuckers.
I cracked them, though.
This is disrespectful behavior.
They took it.
They had catalyzed it.
They catalyzed it.
I cracked two of them.
We got to kill them.
I'm not going to play anymore unless we kill these guys.
Okay, go, go, go.
You go first.
Okay.
Where are you actually doing it?
Wait, I'm getting shot.
Are we gonna...
Are we gonna eat them?
Yeah, as soon as I...
Who's flying?
I have no shield cells, guys.
You guys have extra shield cells.
Oh, they're gonna eat them!
Oh, okay.
Nice.
See, I told you we shouldn't have gone for it.
Yeah.
What is that wall?
Does anyone have extra shield cells?
I only have bats.
Who the fuck plays Newcastle?
Are you guys okay in the head?
I have G.
I can give you one here.
Yeah, I'll give you a bat for it.
Okay.
Nice way.
50...
Ow, dumbass.
i'm gonna go above okay so i can get a better angle i'm
gonna look over here i'm gonna put us probably over there
we're not even top 10.
right chill why aren't we top 10.
because people are not dying fast and what do you mean from
me tell them to die faster i'm literally working on it i was
about to eliminate that team but you guys didn't come i did
i did i was like i'm ready i'm not i Oh, they're fighting on
your...
Oh, okay, okay.
Mother, murder.
I got murder on my mind.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Down here, down here.
I'm straight beaming.
I'm coming over.
I got 15% and I'm about to start porting us to a better
spot.
These motherfuckers over here cannot take our spot.
I will fight them to death.
Wait, I'm getting shot at.
How dare he?
Who are you?
Okay, I have no cell.
Up here.
5%, 3%.
Where are you?
Here, three cells.
Stop peeking.
I'm going to peek because I have a badge.
i gave you a battle so okay we need to go and and i'm gonna
get us to the spot that we need to go to we're so poor get
it out here he's so low you're gonna kill him kill him kill
him kill him on me take the port take the port take the port
take the port i'm in the port i'm in the port okay we play
here we play safety here this corner okay we're gonna get
pushed from there and everywhere honestly we're gonna get
just wait i have a package i'll put a package right here put
a package for cover perfect oh my god i'm charging myself
even though we don't have cells Even though we don't have
cells, I'm charging my sentinel.
I don't give a fuck.
Guys, I have more bats for us.
Here, guys, guys.
Perfect.
Take this, take that.
Take the evo.
Take the evo cash.
I'm gonna scan.
Guys, take the evo cash, guys.
Okay, okay.
I'll take it.
Oh, I'll take it.
There you go.
Look at that.
Why did you take it, Doki?
Because I'm lifeline.
I don't need it.
I'm lifeline.
Oh, no, that motherfucker.
I don't my ass.
They're going to come.
We look.
There's people behind us, by the way.
I miss.
I'm looking at the team behind us.
Holy shit.
It's bugged.
The game's bugged.
There's no way I miss this much.
They're sitting here too.
I'm going to have two more left.
I think they're on the other side of the wall.
Yeah, there's teams here too.
I hear them on the wall.
Oh, he's here.
Here, here, here, here.
Whoa, I'm batting.
Holy shit, there's a lot of people on our here.
I know one.
Nice.
Everyone stay away from my...
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm scared, guys.
They're gonna come.
We fuck everyone.
In front of us, in front of us, in front of us.
Yeah, they're dying.
They're dying.
Chill, chill, chill.
Take it easy.
Don't be queasy.
Right on me, right on.
Big alone, big alone.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm batting, I'm batting.
down here look look here look here look here they killed the
team behind us behind us behind us here here here oh no no
we need to focus this team no this team on northeast yeah
but be careful there's three oh my god who are you fighting
ducky people behind us okay okay i'm looking at ditto i'm
looking at ditto i'm looking for ditto help ditto i'm here
help me help me help me help me I'm getting low.
Oh my god, I'm the mother fucking best.
Oh my god.
All dead, all dead, all dead.
Fuck VTubers.
Guys, this might be the most chaotic game and I have no idea
what's going on.
They're fighting, you're fighting.
They're fighting, they're fighting.
Let them fight.
Don't let them know that we exist.
We don't exist right now.
Can I poke?
I'm poking.
Yeah, poke, poke.
They're so low though.
Oh my god.
this is so exciting i kept one here i'm so pumped right now
guys we're doing it guys this is so chaotic why are you
shooting me focus on the guy in your building i am batting
oh there's one team below one team above and me getting an
angle right now and i'm murdering healing fuck this guy's
door if you have a need fuck this guy's door okay okay i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna Do it!
I'm gonna do it!
Do it!
Fuck his door!
He doesn't need it!
Did I hit it?
Get door, fuck idiot.
100!
Guys, I don't have nades anymore, guys.
I missed, I missed.
He's shooting.
Oh, they're running out.
Oh no.
They're shooting each other.
Oh no, 88.
Oh no.
He's unlucky too!
Kill that world, huh?
Oh, they're fucking each other!
Yeah!
They're rezing!
They're rezing with gold knock!
Throw nades!
Throw nades at them!
I don't have nades!
Why are you pushing so close?
You're crazy.
I love it.
That's good He got the extra.
He got a star.
Yeah!
This one, he's one!
TSM!
Oh my god!
Thank you.
Well, it's like a TSM copy pasta.
Well...
That's right.
We're replacing Hal.
Do I have like 200 things?
I did like TK damage.
Damn.
We're just better.
I did fuck all that game.
I wasn't even playing.
I was barely there.
Won't you?
We're so good.
Guys, practice over, guys.
Let's go back to bed.
Yeah, let's just, it's over.
We know how this game is going to go.
Yeah, no, I mean, honestly, like, you know, team slightly
manhara.
That's our name.
Team slightly manhara.
We're team slightly manhara.
Yeah, honestly, I vote for that.
Team slightly manhara, because this game is going to put me
in an early grade.
I'm going to name myself Imperial RPR.
Imperial RPR.
Oh, my God.
I'll remain myself Doki reps.
So you should just be Depp's.
And Der Holst.
Did Holst.
It's over for everyone in this lobby.
TSM is here.
We're rep- oh my god.
We had 13 kills.
How do we get 13 kills?
I feel like we did nothing all day.
To be fair, I don't know what we were doing.
I was so confused this entire game.
I only shoot and straighten.
me oh my god i'm depths let's go der holst der holst depths
and imperial rpr
we're back tsm is back guys we're gonna win the trophy on
top got on god
I told you I watched zero's what like yeah, I see you know,
I dedicate this win to zero Oh god, I couldn't have done
like he did like he didn't have enough.
Yeah, yeah
He needs it He needs a third trophy.
Yeah, give him another one.
Look, he so he was so sad You see how sad he was it made me
feel so bad when he didn't win yeah but like rc won and
ditto is on our oh true so we have world champion in our
team we can't lose this tournament oh my god we have tsm rc
and dark zero on our team oh yeah yeah yeah dark zero is our
pr i'm tsm and then ditto is rc we literally have the full
champion championship lobby it's over we have so many
trophies it's just Yeah, it's over for everybody.
Like, they should just uninstall right now.
Just end the scrims early.
We can already see how it's going to end.
I've trolled this entire game, and we won.
Like, I'm kind of sure what we're going to fucking do.
Bro, you did a fucking finisher.
I've been playing Flatline Sentinel.
like did you and i were so confused that last fight like in
the fight right before the last fight i jumped in and no
scope the revenant for 88 i think like all three of us were
fighting different teams we were all fighting different
teams during the last fight this is the most unserious i've
ever been in my life like what's gonna happen if we actually
do serious shit okay to be fair to be whole lobby might be a
bit more serious I was just no scoping people would say I
was strolling so hard like who the fuck please flatline
Sentinel it's you you're you're metacrafting you're
metacrafting I'm frontlining with a scent I'm pouring in no
scoping people this is the strat guys if you're not doing
that shit you're not winning land exactly guys guys this is
it that's what RC did brought a sentinel in right ditto yes
yeah ditto give us some rc strats how do they do it how do
they win land because because um i'm the fourth player first
player should they four be three then that one yeah so they
cheated because so they're hacking yeah destroyer are you
destroyer actually actually i won with tn clash and we got
champion oh that's true that's true that's true this is it
fourth player no way we might we might actually lose a few
games to like not show them our true power that's true i
and then we fuck them up on saturday
i wonder who we did the finisher on we should have asked who
did we who got finished by
How did you finish?
Yeah, who did we finish anyway?
I wonder if anybody's gonna...
Oh, it was...
In...
What was it?
In the city.
Oh.
Oh, they're both...
Oh, yeah, they're both cities.
Oh, geez.
City.
I guess we'll never know.
They're too embarrassed to admit it.
Who is even the best team?
The second best team?
team i guess like the team three team three has 10 kills
who's in team three this person is not gonna admit i
finished him come on give me the juice i gave you the truth
chad stream snipe for us ghost for us who was it there's no
stream this person's
said, I wish it was me.
Wait for it.
Someone said it was Nia's team.
That's why she's not speaking up.
She's not going to give me the one.
Just look at her vibe.
There's no stream delay.
Did I finish Nia exactly?
Dude, I hope I did.
For free?
Oh my God, you're giving Are you shooting for free, RPR?
No, there's no way I finished Nia, right?
How much would you charge?
Holy, why is the plane so loud?
All right, RPR, you're a jump master.
Yes.
Okay, listen.
One person lands on this building, one on this building, one
on this building.
Then we loot towards this building.
Okay, I call this building.
You go there.
I go here.
Where am I going?
you have to open this one oh hold up left middle right not
this one left middle right i'm going here i'm going right
side you're going right side yeah yeah because i would been
okay okay oh my god this team is over what do you mean we
got first the moment we win the second game nobody's gonna
catch up to us there's no way we can't around if we win two
games in a row no but like if we don't win we make it we
make it intense on purpose but why they think they have a
chance and definitely no but if they think they don't have a
chance they'll give up and then it'll be even easier on on
saturday yeah but like look imagine how much more soul
crushing is the thinking you have a chance and that's
actually our ultimate move and we show them that they never
really had a to begin with i'm here to ruin jeans early i
might be a sadist i might be a nice that's pretty fucked up
yeah i might be swinging the other way oh my boy so he is
manhara oh my god you are manhara i told you i'm getting
there nice one yeah nice nice let's go team slightly manhara
Hera let's fucking go I'm gonna run double energy that's how
serious I am nah it's time for new era RPR no more getting
bullet now I'm bullying stand in line who's next you can
only bully people who are not in the voice chat that's sad
you're on my team like you want me to bully people like this
is for the benefit of us I have um have a turbo have it oh
we're scammed by a beacon oh it was long shot yeah I need a
scopa oh I'd like these yeah we need a backpack I have these
backpacks are all ass I ain't carrying shit I need massive
massive oh I got a here I have a ball for you I have already
All right, listen to me We're going to move now We're going
to where I'm going I'm ready Monument Oh Monument Okay Our
place There's a Oh We all redeployed Hey Oh my god Go pick
Yeah I found one this time Hey guys I might run out My last
time we walked here There was a team on our right Trying to
shoot us Yeah But we'll shoot back We end their game Quickly
Yeah Yeah, we're gonna make them uninstall.
They won't even show up on Saturday.
Holy shit!
Yeah, I'm in my psycho era.
It's over there.
It's over there for everyone.
Three times.
Oh, I need that.
Okay.
Yay!
I'm in my psycho era.
I mean, it's just over.
He's 14 Severe, Manera, and all it took was one game.
hey one we keep winning it's going to keep going up the more
we win the crazier we get our power levels increase all
right let's go let's go all right oh we go up oh yes
following you yeah i was gonna bet why he's scanning us now
he has to die god kill him god kill him what what are you
boy you're why are you looking at us hey do you want to go
yeah yeah we should kill him wait now this guy's gonna die
next okay who are we killing first right or left i can't
figure it out i can't figure it out right now i'm thinking
oh my god guys he's actually thinking i don't know but
someone's gonna die i know that much someone's dying who why
should he go i'm going straight in
fragment zone what zone would it be this zone up here all
right then we should head over there right i want to go scan
there yeah but let's let's scan to see how many people are
around us okay okay i'm right behind you
oh we should have hit the old charger on the right we just
walked by it like a bunch of dumbasses like we're really
just there we don't need it We don't need it.
Yeah, we don't need that.
You're right.
We're so much better.
I can call it Pakistan.
Or I can call it now.
Put it on the roof.
Put it in the roof.
Okay.
While detours scanning.
There's a PK here.
Call Rumi.
Don't worry.
I'll put it on the roof next to you.
That's your cover.
Yeah, that's the touch.
That's not gonna give it.
I see that.
Oh my god.
That's your cover.
I see dead people.
I see dead people here.
Oh, no.
Oh no.
They died.
Let's go.
Wait, wait.
I think this one might be there.
because everyone is going there.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Zon is probably not like I thought.
Wait, you're wrong.
This guy's died.
Let's go.
Let's go, let's go.
I'm right here behind you, RPR.
What if they shoot back?
They have crypto.
There's no way these guys can shoot back.
That's fucked up.
Yeah, but it's true.
I see them there.
Kasami?
Drop blue armor just like us.
okay and yeah blue armor blue armor they're your own blue
armor wow what are we scared we just want a game what are we
scared of blue armor that guy was hit 109 the caustic i got
detected by the drone i put him on put him on life support
what are we scared of what are we scared of they're not
they're rising come climb with me on the side here me too
i'm climbing i fucked up the climb.
I forgot how to climb this.
They threw any cupstick on me.
I'm gonna pour to you guys.
Come here.
Okay.
I'm waiting.
It's on my side.
Guys, why do they throw it?
They threw a cupstick on my side, guys.
They threw a cupstick on.
I can't do anything.
Dito, you go to the port.
I'm gonna climb.
Okay.
Guys, I got it.
You tried to climb it 14 times.
Good job you did it.
I got off.
Dito, you got off.
That should be, like, on the bottom.
Dito, we need you to shoot.
yeah break holders how dare they deeply wait only see one
person yeah i see one guy they don't get don't get food they
might be cheating they might have anti-wall hack okay i'm
going at the bottom okay we're gonna send this them wait
wait wait wait it's just one guy where's his teammate no his
teammate is in the corner here he is where the fuck is two
guys oh they never rest yeah no That's a valuable comb that
would have been good to me.
Give me Dorn.
Dorn.
Oh, you're right.
You guys know I'm lifeline.
Lifeline player.
You guys know?
TSM.
We gotta move.
There's places we have to be at.
Who scanned us?
I don't know.
You're here.
Here.
Yeah.
Behind us.
behind us that way are they now we got to go up the hill we
can't be we can't be put into i have redeploy okay no no
we're walking they're flying they're flying yeah because
like by the time the redeploy hits and they're they're gonna
take the spot listen i know my timings i want zero yeah but
zero predicts his his zones correctly you didn't predict
your zone correctly we won't last game didn't we i have and
this look what i pinged and it's in zone it's in third zone
like we're still chilling i have package guys oh hey bats i
have like six bats i'm good i have i have eight eight bats
oh i should take that then listen listen listen i know where
this is gonna end and i think we're in an opportune moment
to win this game again where where do we go where here we
stay here okay okay yeah we play from this side everyone's
gonna listen everyone right now is thinking oh my god i have
to get in sermon camper i'm never gonna get in the circle
but no one is thinking about like there's only 11 squads
alive there's no one gonna be on our side of the circle
we're just gonna be being chilling all game yay i'm trying
to figure out a climb again guys i don't remember i can
climb guys i'm gonna practice parkour guys why are you
shooting at us
on top yeah yeah oh my god guys i figured it out there's
nobody here on the side where are they oh so far oh no i
dropped i'm gonna be a mountain goat while you guys are oh
my god i was turning my ac on now you gotta die where are
you getting shot at wait there's people there from the house
yeah probably army oh don't die don't die i was yeah i'm
going to raise you now are you pushing they're coming
they're coming they're coming so oh all right time to murder
them on the right you're fine right i'm gonna bat in front
of me i'm going to die oh no this is not very opportune for
me guys okay and they oh my god guys okay i won't this is
not my fault i was climbing i was climbing guys i was
climbing a mountain i don't this one when you literally gave
him a kill like you presented a free opportunity for this
thing there is no way i will take blame for this i was
climbing a mountain i had no it calms you just sat on some
rock getting beamed by three dudes and you died i mean like
they had purple armor where was our purple armor okay and
that's fine that's fine because they have 25 health more
does that mean you just died yeah i could have killed that
guy that shot me if i had full hp if i had purple i would
100 kill him right ditto yeah yeah you know what i'm capable
of you know what i'm capable that you didn't think of what
are you doing i am now going to assess the situation by
myself i don't have rewind on
I'm going to water you anyway tomorrow.
What the fuck is that sound?
What?
What sound?
What was that?
It's from you, Arpio.
Yeah, what was that?
Are you in the office?
It's like a silent, silent sound.
No, did you not hear like the fucking office sound from him?
Yeah.
Wait, you guys can hear something?
Yeah, it was...
Yeah, we heard it.
heard like a fucking microwave or something oh yes yeah i
don't know a microwave what the fuck where was the microwave
from what what is something dying we heard a microwave i was
like yeah we heard it am i dying i can't believe it i blame
like i think like rpr is actually I didn't make no sounds
there was like a microwave and like a truck or something
he's actually manhira oh my god guys no but you like gas
lighting there right now like no we heard it Ditto Ditto you
heard it too right yeah you're on twitch right now right
yeah yeah yeah get me clip clip guys the chad get that sound
that was so giving me clipp I'm actually confused no we
heard it didn't i heard it yeah no i get i get that you
heard some but like i'm i'm confused like what i will like
what will make a beep sound in my room like a ghost a
fucking ghost your pc got your pc got haunted maybe it's a
bomb bomb oh my god this guy's on controller can we get him
banned which one there's so many this should have been a pc
m and k tournament only i request yeah i thought you guys
were playing control that's the easy way out on god wait
people are copying our com now they are of course they are
we're doing we're trendsetters we're like innovates we
created this cop algs copy cheating he must just andy
do you have the clip yo i don't have the creep someone
claiming somebody clip clip clip clip we need to find it
like listen do you have my craft in your room if you have no
i don't have you in my i don't even have a microphone in my
house are there like trucks outside it's a 2 a.m what the is
the truck gonna be a 2 a.m trucks can drive at 2 and the
morning i live in bug fuck nowhere oh trucks can still exist
not i have a big garden there's a there's a long while until
the road maybe there's like a truck nearby like where in my
garden
maybe it's like a baby truck yeah no That's that's yeah,
that's correct.
That's the correct one.
You got it there Yeah, I knew I was right You got me.
I got a baby truck in my gun That makes sense hot trucks in
your area Okay, it's too far Did you get get the clip did oh
he thinks we're crazy I should say no, I'm not giving the
yeah, okay?
Why are you getting the clip?
Chat, we need...
Someone claim it for me.
Someone clip it, guys.
We need to prove that we're not crazy and RPR is crazy.
Wait, did you have the clip?
Here, here, here, here, here.
Oh, here, here, here.
He has the clip.
I was saying, open chat here.
Are we putting him in the open chat so everybody can see
the...
Wait, where did you post it?
Okay, um, here.
Hello, I'm back.
That got assassinated.
Oh, okay, here, we got the clip for you, RPR.
My intern got assassinated by someone.
This is not fair.
I got code net.
You got code net?
No, my whole intern died.
Your whole intern died.
But I'm going to watch this clip.
I'm watching this clip, too.
Okay, that song.
Yeah, this is a sound I heard.
What's that?
Yeah, what the fuck is that?
Wait, what the fuck?
That's...
There's a ghost.
a dog dog also what is that yeah don't are fear scared now
he's scared yeah it's from you yeah it was from because you
didn't hear but we heard it
guys yeah it's a bit scary that even he's confused like
no but like it's a little worried nothing nothing here is
capable of making that sound except for my ac or my pc oh it
could is that could be an ac sound i mean maybe my ac went
crazy for a little bit and go like beep beep but like why
would you why would you do that did you not hear it is your
headphones like no i i have in ears so i don't hear shit
outside oh i can't hear anything in my room you could stab
me the ac actually your ac went fucking crazy there why did
it go that it could be a go well you can't explain what
ghost wants to do why is he yapping like that because the
ghost hates you i don't fucking know what did you do i'm not
afraid of ghosts i'm afraid of faulty equipment when you get
your ac checked i just bought this new one Oh, it's a lemon
Can they end the game faster So we can like go back to
destroying this lobby Look, if like Our PR didn't throw,
we'd be first place Right, Ditto You literally fell over
Like a You didn't cover Yeah, you didn't cover me Sorry, I
didn't cover I only cracked one person that was shooting at
you But so that I couldn't crack all three at the same time
While you're standing like the statue of Jesus Christ on top
of a mountain like hello well I'm glad that you agreed with
me like I apologize it's not my fault well it's not mine or
Ditto's fault it could be ditto's fault though yeah why
didn't you cover rpr and i no he has he's a pro he can't
cover himself that's so true wait that's so true though pro
players now i'm going to go pee now i need my five minutes i
need my time off this team for a couple minutes we consider
this a smoke break
We're not the problem here, right Ditto?
We're not the problem.
He's the...
Yeah.
We did like everything correctly.
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh, that's so sad.
Up here always blaming...
I know!
He always blames...
That's why he retired.
Yeah.
you're so right that would be so mad
that's why that's why we say it when he's in the bathroom
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I thought he can share us no he
can't no he can he doesn't have enough money for wireless
and their wireless headphones oh my god
It's okay.
We're...
Guys, it's okay.
Well, we're gonna win this next one.
Yeah, yeah, sure.
If RPR didn't throw, we win.
Yeah, I know!
He was trolling!
He was trolling us!
Like, he said this spot was, like, the best spot.
And then we died.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's so messed up.
He truly is a Minhera.
Can we die when we get the base spot?
Yeah, I know, right?
If it's the best spot, we wouldn't have died.
That is so true.
It would...
The best spot means that we should live.
Like...
Oh,
she's coming back.
Welcome back, RPR.
Oh, he's not back.
RPR, welcome back.
We missed you.
Toilet one was taken, so I had to pee in toilet two.
Nice.
Hey, we missed you, RPR.
We're, like, talking about good you whereas I, yeah.
I don't know if I stop fucking lying to my face.
Are you trying to say Ditto would lie?
She said yes.
Yes.
Duggie, the last time I told him that my favorite Apex
player was up here, and he didn't believe me.
Wow!
That's fucked up.
You're not a hero.
You're only second to zero.
10 there's about 15 players that are before me
yeah but like we know you so you're ahead of those 15
players yeah but you also know nocturnal fun like five more
ahead of me how ver halls um yeah yeah i keep adding yeah
this is really helping your case this is really helping your
case Yeah, okay.
But, but, but you're like second to zero.
You don't even know zero.
Not yet.
Okay.
But he's already ahead of me.
Great.
Tough.
it's okay this time this time will we'll win first right are
you yeah no if my teammate doesn't turn into a statue and
die right now pay attention i'll pay attention this time
yeah that'll be that'll be good that'll be the plus it's
okay we got this i believe in us i believe in believing we
win this yeah we win this it's gonna get 20 20k bomb for us
yes yes yeah yeah yeah if she doesn't get 4k we kick her
okay if you lose it's rpr fault yeah it will lose its rpr as
well okay but like why okay i'm like trying you ideal in tsm
when tsm lost it was how's fault so you yeah so is since
we're new tsm it's your fault because your igl first of all
it wasn't a house fault it was always evan or jordan okay
but was never me okay but the chat says it's house fault
yeah but chat's always gonna blame the enemy they're like
the most popular player on the team is always at fault wait
but it's not my fault fault it's absolutely your fault every
single time without fail oh maybe there's someone yes oh no
don't fly away it's rpr that's near why i want i want to be
with you until until death yeah like this team is just made
to ruin my mental health this is insane so i wait team
slightly manhara no no no we are team totally manhara right
now team severe manhara team i'm just like over the edge it
only takes one bad day it takes one day you need to be bad
just one day here okay oh he got i got i got it all right
nice yeah supreme manhara i'm gonna Yeah, hiatus number two,
I think.
Maybe number three.
Maybe we'll combine a couple.
Wait, wait, what?
Ooh!
Yeah.
I'm going not.
Nice.
I have a destructor here if anyone wants it.
Okay.
It's all obvious.
I'm...
I'm using Nemesis and Monastive.
All right.
I am Hemlock Nemesis, but I'd rather have Hemlock Havoc.
Because I heard Havoc is, like, the gun now.
It's the only gun in the game.
game you ever need.
If you have Havoc, you don't need anything else.
What's this hammer point?
I don't need that.
I'm heading over for the knockdown shield.
Oh my god.
I want Havoc.
Yay.
A lot?
Okay.
Actually, I'll find a Havoc for us.
That's not my job.
I tell you what to go and not what to look.
Wait, there's a Havoc here where Ditto is and she didn't
ping it.
Oh, I didn't see it.
I didn't see it.
Wow!
Ditto what?
I didn't lose.
I didn't see.
I'm your fault.
He didn't tell me.
How am I supposed to tell you what you're seeing?
You're so right.
Venated.
I can't give it to you.
I'm so sorry.
How am I supposed to tell you like what you're looking with
your own eyes?
What do you want?
You have to say, yeah.
You weren't certain of it though.
Yeah, there's no way I could know what you want.
English is her third language, RPR.
You have to be more.
It's my 14th language.
Don't get here, here.
Ooh, nice.
Thank you.
I'm getting hungry.
I need a backpack.
That's not white.
There's a...
Ooh, I'll take that, actually.
I need a Havoc.
I need energy.
Energy.
helmet here okay yeah energy magazine what are these stupid
zones i don't know igl what are they monument hey listen
tell me this map doesn't tell me okay i was scared i can't
read okay don't worry our better player is gonna scan for us
okay it is the one there i'm with you ditto if you need help
our igl is not with us because you're supposed to follow me
not the other way around yeah but we we were scanning yeah
we have to scan if you were a player now you would know why
why why don't you wait for us yeah did i did i say we need a
scan yeah yes when first game first game yeah this is a game
After first game comes it's different.
Okay, okay.
Where do we go?
She's unbelievable.
Just follow me!
Follow me!
Follow me behind me!
Okay.
Yay!
I will only follow you.
Yeah, we're following you.
Only follow you.
I'm not gonna go anywhere.
Yeah, yeah, we'll only follow you.
Good.
We won't think for ourselves.
Yeah.
This is the shit I got.
Even they are alone.
I think they are low.
I'm going to...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I won't shoot.
If he doesn't tell us to shoot, we won't shoot.
Do you guys want to lose?
Like, honestly.
Like, do you guys just want to lose?
But you told us to follow you!
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
When we're rotating, of course!
But what if somebody shows up while we're rotating?
Do we shoot?
It will be a case-by-case command.
I'm going to give you.
Oh okay okay okay.
Yeah okay okay.
I get it I get it.
Yeah, I'm gonna I will I follow you.
Yeah, we follow you TSN T.
Oh wait, she's scanning.
I need a fucking Habok.
I have one.
You want to look at it?
You can win with the Habok.
Wasn't there a team here?
This thing is broken.
Yeah, there was team here.
Yeah, but they are gone because they're going zone.
Okay, I will.
I will.
We got it.
Yeah, we got scanning.
again yeah let's scan again like great guys iGL should we
scan again iGL yeah guys no no yeah iGL should we do it just
rip it yeah let's do let's do four more scans by the way do
the respawn beacon are they gonna res nope that's three
people what the people what do you mean kill them anyway
where are we going almost crack the 500 what the fuck crack
two i'll play I can't I can't crack anyone higher She's just
lying now There's a purple helmet I have so many batteries I
have a battery again There's three people that's there's
three teams at sky hook I'll tell you in a second Yes I
don't I would redeploy anyone use it we all have redeploys
Yeah, but I do I really want the fucking havoc.
What is this bullshit game?
I'm having a sky hook I'll put a redeploy here.
Why are you having like now?
Yeah, yeah.
I have redeploy.
Yeah, let's go with redeploy.
They won't know who to shoot!
Yeah, this is a professional strat.
Okay.
I said I wanted to redeploy first.
No, but pros always use multiple redeploys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
See, we're just doing what the pros do.
Exactly.
Adita, where are you walking?
I'm flying a scum!
We're trying to find you a havoc!
Right there?
We're rotating now!
Let's rotate!
Up here!
You can find...
What the heck?
Enemy, enemy, enemy!
Enemy, enemy!
Find these motherfuckers, murder them in cold blood.
Wait, where?
Get this rock.
They shot me, close on me, close on me.
I see him, I see him.
She's right.
I'm on the rock on the rock.
I'm next to you.
Nice one.
Two dead.
Next to me, next to me, next to me.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm with you.
I'm with you.
I'm pushing.
Oh, he is?
I'm gonna go kill him.
There's him then.
Yes.
Hey guys, I have zero damage.
Can I thirst that other guy?
This guy's don't have a fucking havoc.
This guy has a havoc.
The guy that was running has a havoc.
Yeah, but I'm not gonna chase.
I'll show you.
Fuck, let's kill him.
Wait, I want to loot this though.
No, but he's already so.
far yeah he's so far we should go to their plane they're
playing catalyst bloodhound and the last person was what
bangalore they can grab banners let's camp them okay he's
gonna bring me the havoc i promise you well wait he this guy
has a carbine i want a carbine i want to use a carbine hey
i'm dropping a headlock come here sit right here sit on me
all right okay to the new i want to i want this guy to
deliver me a habit i didn't know if he actually does have a
habit i was just i did clean the tube over here who the fuck
is that why do they have purple are they cheating yeah why
do they have purple where's our purple fuck you guys
cheating bro yeah cheating in a sprint what's wrong with you
i keep reinstalling his brain cells let's go of skyhook okay
okay i'm like 900 away from the purple guys i'm 151 you're
really putting in the hard work i am i am i'm gonna scan i
just watch the fence that's scary wait they scanned us from
here oh yeah i need like more show cells hey you found a
habit seven bats nope that was a wall oh yeah one team there
we are we going back to the same house same house and we
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we play exactly the same and then
we kill everyone and they die and we won yay guys we're so
good at this video game wait is there anyone why are they in
the building that i want there's a battery why are you
shooting at me okay Okay, I'm...
There's like a lot of bad...
What the fuck is wrong with people?
They just want to give you a hug.
Come here, let's go to this building now.
What the fuck is... What is this contraption here?
Can you scan this building if there's anyone in there?
You're already in it, so like, what's the point?
No, no, the other one to the right.
Oh, there is.
Three dudes.
Well, they think they can beat us by taking the spot before
us.
That's not how it works.
The Newcastle, though.
What do we do?
Can somebody take my package?
wait for mine wait i'm gonna see what is in the package yeah
why am i lagging now don't get ddos there's a lot of bats
guys yeah i'll take yeah okay there's like more bats here
there's so many bats holy what i mean i'm not saying no i
don't change a bat i'll give you okay i don't know from
where i wasn't paying attention i have seven bats now and
they're probably gonna yeah oh here honestly let's go back
to our building this building is nicer and taller okay yeah
yay on this one more someone's close to me yeah they're
behind us behind the building scan behind from here i can't
wait i hear them phoenixing they're close close close in the
building wait wait one second I hear a lot.
Wait, what?
Are they not in there anymore?
Yeah.
Yeah, where did they go?
They were here.
Yeah, they disappeared.
I don't know, I was probably...
10 seconds?
10 seconds.
You know, I have so many bats, I might as well use it.
Okay, here, over there.
There's like a crypto...
They're in there?
Okay.
They're still there?
Oh, okay.
They went in dying there Guys, stop They're breaking out
doors, now I just want to kill them Stop, guys I think he's
too fast, he's not a bad You guys are pissing me off, you're
pissing me off, give me your feet
Get out of here What do you think you're doing, huh?
What do you think you're doing, huh?
Can you stop shooting from all the way up there, dumbass?
No Well, I didn't have to shoot from far They are so far but
this they sure does Let's go next building over Legs
building over Okay Okay Where's the next building This one
right front Okay I think there's a big team here I think
there's a team here Yeah yeah Yeah we fight these guys That
guy's low Oh my god Okay Oh no clear Doki where were you
Behind you behind you Where was I Where did you shot from a
different team?
Where did you shot my team on the other side?
No, no, no, no, no.
That was a bad call.
That was one- How is that a bad call?
There was literally a team shooting us to our right.
How is this a bad call?
Let's take this building.
There's a team here.
Me and Ditto are there, but Docky is nowhere to be found.
I was getting shot by a team to our right.
What do you mean?
How did you make that happen?
Because you guys were also getting shot by that same team.
I was literally watching it happen.
didn't get hit.
I didn't get hit.
That is not true.
Look at the death free cap.
No, no, no.
I'm not going to be blamed for this.
I got shot by three different people.
Look at your death free cap.
You're not looking at your death free cap because you know.
Once again, this is your fault.
How is it my fault?
I got shot by a new castle.
This team doesn't have a fucking new castle.
So you get shot by mucus like I did.
Look at your death recap.
No, I have not No, I have death recap.
You're fucking lying.
It's catalyst in Bangalore to hit me You don't have a
catalyst Yeah, but I healed the I healed the damage that
catalyst did to me
Yeah, but I catalyst cracked me.
I popped a bat and then we pushed What you mean you were so
low by the other team yeah why are you guys getting hit and
i'm not getting hit doesn't make any sense where's your
portal yeah where's your portal why would we port for five
feet what we wouldn't get shot soccer dodging like i can't
help you oh you were also the one that got shot to like nope
what about you pushed yeah okay i got a shot wow before you
pushed but when we pushed i was straight dodging that you
literally said you got shot by bangle or yeah i can't
believe it i've got through so hard no but like where were
you you know like i was right behind you guys getting shot
by the other team but the whole team is here except for
dokey's dokey not part of the with you guys i was literally
with you guys i was with you guys i was about to res you
because you died outside the door and then you crawl inside
of course i'm gonna cry why did you cry inside i could
there's no doors to begin with they broke the door i could
have res you i could have res you outside of the house and
you're telling me that if you i could have res you outside
the house and then i could have killed like bangalore you
could have got free res because nobody was pushing you
outside the house you could have done so much but instead
you're sitting here dead and yapping like you died first i
died for the team yeah i died for the team too you died last
so you didn't die for the team i know it's it's right that
um it's not good that i've like dying first yeah that's so
true ditto yeah that's so true on her side she just left us
in a two with three that is not true it was like a one v two
from what i saw it was a two with three it was a 1v2 i saw
it there was like one guy in there oh my god now she's just
gaslighting you know what maybe rpr should play lifeline
yeah you should i gel and then it's easy okay no no no
actually i can be on lifeline i just cannot be on like what
where are you pulling this where are you pulling this back
where are you pulling your stats from from years of
experience
you you haven't been in competitive play for so long meta
changed listen to me how the fuck his lifeline gonna i gel
when he has to be behind his whole team how how is he gonna
i gel when he literally has to be behind everyone what is he
gonna tell them yeah you guys go there yeah you fuck him up
boys yeah yeah i got your back i mean you gotta try it out
and see how much better it is i'm not gonna listen i'm gonna
do this stupid shit we're gonna play proper apex legends
dude how come we died i would explain your mistakes to you
like are you like an m you want to hear them over and over
again like you just want me to keep on you i mean you're the
reason why we died though
why are you five seconds late to the move five seconds late
i was like one second stop the gap that fight was like at
least 10 seconds long
we're not winning guys oh you're very high way oh you're not
winning oh yeah who's i'm gonna murder you like the second
game you're standing still like a statue get the beam from
across the planet we get pushed and now you know with the
team and you gaslight and then you crying we're now winning
like what more can I do what more can I do what more can I
do what more can he do doc is literally you the second game
you literally that statue on top of rio de janeiro jesus
that's on the rugged above the clouds wait calm down calm
down their their eye chills on bloodhound their eye chills
on bloodhound i feel like fuck what they do they're
obviously worse than us they killed us we didn't kill us we
died to you this guy's ranked 26th spread when have you been
fucking worn a fucking championship like you're gonna
compare me to a ranked 26 spread He's playing in
kindergarten while I was competing in the NBA like what are
we talking about But what was your peak rank?
It was top 10 You know no number for that?
No, I don't remember it was me knocking raptor we grinded
one season to top 10 then we stopped But did you end on top
10?
I have better shit to do like winning tournaments instead of
playing ranked what is wrong with you wait this guy the team
that killed us won they're called THC they're high as fuck
and they won against but
these motherfuckers are high out of their mind they probably
popped a fucking edible my fucking said every set of boys
beaming okay we go next yeah yeah it's the next map oh wait
that's the good map okay we go this and in the next game if
um who died first that is um their fault okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i agree i agree nah this is so stupid like
why are you guys so focused on who's dying first and who's
instead of winning the game what are you focusing on that's
that's how we know up here you're starting you you're
starting you're always blaming people you guys don't
understand that when you you don't understand when you're
the igl you get blaming privileges if you want to blame
other people go ahead and igl
him i think um come down yeah come down arpear calm down
this is just a scrum why take oh yeah yeah the best thing to
tell them is to calm down yeah that's really smart for me
guys so we're really gonna help out here it's okay arpear
just slow down it's just a scrum you don't have to take this
so seriously yeah you literally five minutes before you were
crying why are we
like did or not we're just here to have a good time right
did oh yes yeah so it doesn't matter if we don't win i mean
oh yeah now it matters huh i mean really the algs champion
winner not winning a simple scrim against i don't care
personally i'll go yeah that doesn't look good for you
though i mean i don't care i'm gonna get my win one way or
another through this tournament
are we doing the same same comp of course we are what the
fuck are we gonna switch up oh i don't know it's a different
map different map same shit it's just different packaging
like who cares bangalore not not doing fuck is bangalore
gonna do for us patience because like you're not making
portals for us i made 15 portals just in the first game yeah
but that's the first game what about the second and third
there was zero portals then god i couldn't port you anyway
you died so fast it was over too quick what was i gonna port
to the next lobby that's better than no port
We will do Beijing in Stone Point.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're going to try so hard.
My game crashed.
Yeah, I was trying so hard right now.
I'm coming back in.
I'm going to try suck crashes.
Don't worry.
Now, after I get back in, I'm going to try so hard.
We're still cold.
We tell them not to start yet.
I crashed.
Oh, I'm a giant.
I mean, you could play...
Oh, no.
Why do we...
Why do we want to be meta slaves?
You know what I mean?
Why not...
Because we're not winning.
We're not winning because of the comp, but like...
It really aimed the comp form.
It could be the comp issue.
It could be...
Wait, we'll see...
What's the code?
Okay, what comp would you play?
I don't know.
You're the IGL.
So if you want to switch the comp, but you don't have any
fucking ideas what to do then why do you say i want to swap
i'm just giving a suggestion uh suggestions from here on out
are banned wait we're fourth place guys we're not even
second yeah okay from here on out suggestions are banned
wait that's up i make the rules i gel if you want to make
the rules you can i gel okay but that's like That's pretty
fucked up.
Okay, let's do it.
Okay, we listen.
We listen to up here.
Yeah, we're good listeners.
Okay, okay.
If we listen to you and we don't win first, then I think
that's just an IGL problem at that point.
Yeah.
I will listen to every...
Yeah, I'm going to listen to every calm you say.
And like, I will make sure I wouldn't be super 100% focused.
So if you don't listen, what happens?
What if you don't listen?
Well, it's never going to happen.
What if your ADHD kicks in?
I don't have any HD.
You're a streamer.
I don't have ADHD.
I got tested.
I just diagnosed you.
Where's our land again?
I don't know.
Okay.
Well, there's a barometer.
Yeah, I heard it.
See, if I had ADHD, I wouldn't have heard it.
You heard it five minutes after I said it.
this is the com trust me i've done this for years i always
played lifeline bloodhound and raid yeah but like you
retired years ago so you think i'm just fucking a person
retires and just gets dumb like just forgets what it's like
riding a fucking bike you never forget this shit same shit
just different Yeah, but the game's dog shit like it was two
years ago.
It's still the same shit.
No, but you, no, now we have EVO armor.
We had that shit two years ago, too.
No, we don't.
We did have EVO armor for two years.
That was a year ago.
No, we had EVO, we had EVO armor for years.
We just didn't have this stupid shit that you can't charge
anymore.
Yeah, but we didn't have skills, too.
but dog shit skills wow what a big change it's so different
now you can have your armors don't spawn in anymore now you
can you can have your horizon queue 5% faster than before
wow yeah but you said it's the same game and i'm here to
prove to you that it's not the same game it's the same it's
the same dog shit that they just packed package in a
different box and they're doing this shit every season yeah
but we had new legends too we have wow everyone uses don't
forget everyone uses this this altar legend ever she's so
useful that just people just part of every comp it's
unbelievable useful there's a gold gold sent and not go send
gold we also have vantage that that one is also very well
conduit wow conduit one team in 15 teams uses conduit META
at one point Yeah, for like five minutes and then they
fucking murdered her What about Catalyst?
Catalyst was like Catalyst was out when I was competing It
doesn't count
We don't count that one We don't count it but he's new He's
new She's not new if she came out Two years ago Hey, here's
a havoc Okay, you're on the hallway Yeah, there's a havoc
Oh, now you don't want our havoc legs oh yeah let me
quadruple wield fucking havocs because i got four hands you
could dual wield it nothing's stopping you from that one
shotgun like do you want to lose no we're listeners right
we're listening yeah we're listening to you yeah we're
listening to you you guys are doing great job of listening
i'm glad you're listening there's some real high quality
listening yeah we say that we we will listen to you but we
didn't we didn't promise you that we are gonna do what you
say oh okay oh okay so you just want to lose so she says
she's just planning to lose i didn't say that yeah we we
will do what you say okay we will do what you say okay i'm
making i'm making the why don't you try i'm trying i'm
making a battery i can't no you don't you have us you guys
if you guys are my therapist it will be over we'll do it for
free that's how good friends we are now i'll pay you to stay
away from me wait am i on like 280 let me double check guys
i don't think i'm on the right frames how much frames do you
need i think i'm on am i on 60 no i'm on 200 okay there we
go Don't worry guys, my eyes were just tired.
There we go.
Don't worry, my eyes were just tired.
I just said movement.
All right, here you are.
Move now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm right behind you.
I'm right behind.
Ditto's not listening.
Okay, what are we in kindergarten?
Like, hello?
She's not listening, teacher.
Okay, I'm like, I'm going.
Have you taken this seriously for a second?
Why are we following you?
Yeah, when we die, you're going to be like, why are we not
winning?
Why are we not winning?
But why aren't we?
What's your odd?
What's your own odd?
Mr. RPR, can I get a hall pass?
No.
No passes anywhere.
No suggestions, no talking back, nothing.
use the bathroom no you're not going to the bathroom until
we win a game that sounds like i don't know that doesn't
sound right isn't that like against a human right i'm not a
fucking teacher i'm no license one chamber okay oh there's a
team there yeah we killed these fucking spiders and take
their okay okay t true okay hey there's no better oh i want
a bat yeah never mind i want it okay i have six bats you
want in i have four you have six bats give me two yeah wait
there's people over there are we gonna get sandwich yeah are
we no we are going to sandwich them this is all part of my
plan This is all part of a master plan They're right here in
front of me They're right in front of me Okay And their life
Look at his need I'm looking One two Three Bomba There's a
guy on top I'm gonna Send my I'm gonna throw another bomb
Wait there's a There's a guy Are we gonna do Are we gonna
fight Are we fighting or no Well I mean We gotta kill the
guy That's close If we wanna fight There's another bat here
There's so many bats the guy that's closer on a way like why
is he running because there was team behind us there is oh
why are you guys so scared why are they scared of us no i'm
not saying you guys damn guys over there why are they so
scared there's a light mag there purple light mag on my path
is good from here one hp one hp 162 how is he alive he's got
175 that's why he's alive all right i'm here they can't do
the queues they have conduit see they're using conduit
there's some stupid shit you guys are fucking cheating i'm
okay if conduit is cheating then why don't we use conduit i
would just call it bad these guys want to third party us and
he has a long bow now i'm just not gonna fight because he
wants the third parties you're gonna go back to barometer
okay because this game is dog shit and pulled back i'm
waiting for you rpr let's go we take the portal back i have
a redeploy i waited for you to use yours someone is also
redeploying there so we now are in a race of who's gonna die
first not us that's for sure but i'm gonna get shot because
they can't shoot us because i said so in the tunnel you're
right you're so right idea because we listen yes yes get to
this house keep moving to the next house and we don't stop
moving if you stop moving you're dead i'm not gonna pick you
up if you died you're dead wait why didn't you keep your
portal to save us there's no portals in this world that
sounds like a guy that wasn't gonna oh why are you playing i
need a bat i got shot alive you die you're dead okay i'm
alive get to this house now okay climb this up yeah you can
yay we're alive see rpr we listen i'm putting the best spot
in the zone really yes where do you think the zone is gonna
go i don't know your idea who's here i mean jesus does not
love us wait then you're wrong but i'm never wrong But you
were wrong last game I was not wrong the last game we were
in the right spot to win the game you died because you were
rung How was I wrong?
We won the correct spot
you're right, you're right you're always right RFPR because
I am so right so that means if you're always right then we
should win even if the zone does not go to us we have an
easy walk to the zone no matter what and we have double
choices we can even choose over here or go here like we have
so many choices oh my god you're so right i'm washed all
right right sign where should i watch rpr just stay alive
like you did doc you just watch your life stay alive but i
want to contribute you're contributing by being alive but
like i want to do more okay then stare at that house and
stay alive okay but where are you gonna watch what
everywhere i'm literally looking everywhere i'm looking at
the house yep oh i have a package good job guys i got a
package
yay there's more bats and a purple helmet what a shit
package you need you need a purple helmet you know you need
this oh yeah i need it yeah yeah you need to heal you're not
full health dokey go full health now wait drone okay you
told me to heal yeah i mean why do i have to tell you to
heal you shouldn't hold this because i wasn't told i'm the
listener Yeah, you told me to do whatever you say.
She's a baby.
So if you get hit by 150, you're not going to heal.
Until I tell you to heal.
That's what you know.
I quit.
I quit this team.
Find a new Imperial Hall.
No, you're not supposed to leave TSM.
I'm going to Dark Zero.
It's over.
We're all playing now.
a controller player all right this game is wait you got the
zone wrong you're definitely not going to darts you got the
zone we're gonna go for this we're gonna go for this house
okay okay play from there and then the zone is probably
gonna pull here and we're gonna go through this and blah
blah blah let's go reset okay all right i need everyone has
um purple armor now yeah everyone what they can't aim and we
can that's the only thing that matters we are tsm they
killed us though yeah but that was not an aim issue it
wasn't no it was a brain issue on your behalf
get this house is our house yeah yeah we have a house ditto
i will wash our i want this i want this as well i want
everything we're taking it we're we are tsm we can hold
everything look at this guys how dare you crypto do you know
who i am i'm imperial how imperial rpr tell me if they
pushing you they're not i think they're getting all charge
off of not i'll charge shield charge i i i have watched that
if you have a nade break their door but they're just gonna
wall it back yeah so what i'm gonna shoot them in the window
the door is broken why are you coming back with this stupid
fucking drone because they have the resources well there's a
nade here you want to use it you're better at aiming the
nade than us yes i got apparently i that's how it works pro
players have good aim on everything there's an indicator oh
they put it on the door broken shoot them they wait they
they they Did the door thing.
Yeah, we knew that was going to happen.
Then what's the point of needing the door?
Because maybe in the second that I broke the door, I could
see one of them and one clipped them.
But you didn't.
It's a fucking...
It's a gamble!
I hate it here.
I'm going to hold here.
You guys hold there.
Okay.
Okay Wait, it was here, here, here, here.
Here, there, here.
Someone jump.
Kill those motherfuckers now.
We need help.
She's jumping up.
She's still alive.
I know one.
Nice.
This is Nate up.
Nate up.
We go together.
Three, two, one.
Okay, zip take now.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I'm with RPR.
Why don't you be bang?
Bang is one.
I got a heal.
Okay.
And he wants to kill me so bad.
He's a hater.
I got a kill drone out for you.
Whoops.
Hey, I was done.
That was interesting.
That guy wanted to take me down with him.
It was some hater shit.
He was straight hating.
What did you do?
Why is he hating on you?
I don't know.
Some toxic shit.
These VTubers, I swear to God.
Yeah, so toxic.
Oh, I got purple guys.
We all got what's the third person?
Why do we see two dead boxes?
Third person's on the ground, maybe?
Oh, D-thousand.
Oh, there's an alt-xel.
Do we need it?
Let's go next.
You guys stay here.
As I said, I'm going to hold this.
You guys are going to hold the house.
There's a hash.
You guys are going to move it to zone.
Someone's on my right.
I already have this spot.
What the fuck?
But they're in the zone there.
Almost can't almost get on there.
Okay, I'm heading over to you, RPR.
No, no, no, no.
Are you listening?
No, I forgot.
You guys...
You guys hold the fucking house and you move it to the zone.
Yeah, okay, I heard you this time.
Wait, they're behind us rock.
Yeah.
Yeah, they're looking at us.
I'm a mochi.
They're looking at me right here.
Why the fuck are they looking?
Who the fuck...
Ditto, why are you here?
I don't know, but I'm by myself now here.
Now, this is insanity.
No!
Now you...
You're very...
I love that person!
I'm making a port to dodge this stupid fucking Bangalore old
Bangalore's low
I almost cracked Bangalore It's okay, it's okay They're
pushing, they're pushing, blow down pushing On me, on me, on
me I cracked the fuck out of him I got a bat I'm on the side
of the wall by the way I can't They're gonna push us
through, everyone come here Okay, I'm coming back Okay,
they're on me Oh my god, I got beam I need help.
I need help.
Amin.
I mean.
I was with you.
What did you expect from me?
It was Verhost again.
Verhost!
Why were you not thinking?
You got more damage verhost?
Verhost!
it's the fucking controller player again it's heaven all i'm
saying i was i was with imperial rpr i good job nah this
probably got bean by this fucking controller andy hey
where's our who's raven then who's our raven we don't have
raven we don't We don't have the budget for that.
That's why we're losing.
We don't have the budget for that shit.
Right.
Where's your Raven?
Maybe if we won't scream, we would have the budget for it.
Hell took all the budget.
That's why we have a period.
You went to Dark Zero and took everything.
You took all the budget, guys.
Fucking asshole.
I can't believe it.
What is this fight?
What am I watching?
I don't fucking know.
Wait, they won that.
Wait, what?
They got dirty.
That's crazy.
Why couldn't we be the team that didn't have to fight
everybody?
Because we got pushed and there's sometimes in life, you get
pushed and you have to win the push.
And that's what the Apex is all about.
How come we didn't win the push?
We listened to you.
Oh, wait.
I don't think we need life.
Listen, I don't know.
I don't know what you want me to do.
I knocked one and cracked two people in that fight.
I really can't do more than that.
I got my one.
You didn't knock anyone.
There was two guys alive.
I got my one.
I helped you.
What did you knock yourself?
I covered you.
To get you your one.
Okay.
I knocked my one.
Now turn into I covered you.
So you can get your one.
I think you need.
We call it Bangalore, Bangalore.
Yeah, I agree.
And Waisen also are another character.
Okay, Doki, you're not playing Bangalore.
What am I playing?
Bangalore.
I'm playing Bangalore?
Nice.
Honestly, I agree.
And, yeah, sure, that's going to go so much better.
I'm playing Waisen.
Why would you play Waisen?
We need Bloodhound.
and bloodhounds so we can smoke them then wall hack them
yeah we're bloodhound i agree with a bloodhound pick no um
how about another one the last last last character i'm
playing great great because portal is important we have
bangalore smokes yeah okay i how about you tell me bangalore
smoke is gonna port us across the planet yes guys it's
seriously isn't a team comp thing we're not losing to team
comp right now okay to be fair dido didn't their host didn't
listen to that last column to be fair i would admit i i
listen listen bloodhound bangalore rate this is fine it
works wait bangalore okay dido you're your bloodhound oh no
i No, I want to play Bloodhound.
I want to play Bloodhound.
I'm going to play Pathfinder.
No, you're playing Wraith.
You need to be on Wraith.
No, I'm way better on Pathfinder.
No, but what about the portal?
We have Ziplines.
But the portals were important.
Yeah, but Ziplines.
Okay, RITL's throwing.
Go Zipline.
All right, RITL's throwing.
I'll show you this map is made for Pathfinder.
Okay.
I'll show you.
This is Screams.
We have two more games to win a game!
This is screams!
We're trying things out!
We're six plays!
Whose loot is the hat, huh?
That's okay, it's a scream.
But you can win!
We won two games!
No, we won one game.
We won one game, ditto.
No, one-two more games, yeah.
Oh yeah, okay, two more games for us to win.
You're right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
this time and next time yeah and i'm gonna play pathfinder
we can't lose i'll show you the sauce okay so what do we
play then angler and bloodhound how did you forget already
like i don't get it i don't know you're you were saying rage
and then suddenly you swapped the pathfinder so i assume
there's gonna be more swaps i swapped my character not yours
okay i will play more i can see okay if i will shoot like
everyone you you're complaining what i play rate then you
don't want to play path like what do you want me to do i'm
fucking in-game leader i decide what i do you're like you're
like seeing different comps now so i'm confused because
we're screaming this is all about trying shit out yeah but
then you said you didn't need we didn't need to try new
things out because like you guys are so hell bent on trying
things out so now we're really trying things i was fine i
was fine i was fine we're doing whatever was clearly not
satisfied with our team comp so now we're trying things out
okay well time time so who are we blaming then no one why do
you want to blame people why can't we just focus on winning
wait what am i playing when i play binglor yes no yes yes
okay you wanted to simply blow down i'm so confused i'm so
confused reach one reach one do you want to
There's too many swaps I'm getting confused
Oh my god you're frying my brain so I don't have many left
Oh
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Are you okay?
Yeah, I'm fine.
Don't even know what you're playing.
I know I'm playing.
We just talked about five minutes.
Stop, stop, stop.
For five minutes, we talked about team comp.
She was like, I want to play Bloodhound.
And then she goes into lobby.
She's like, what am I playing?
How does it work?
Look, I just got overwhelmed because we keep changing.
aging so Team Rock is already dead.
Oh, they got contested for trouble make it double Wait, they
got contested Oh Whoa, why why they're dead?
Why they're dead because they got contested Oh, I see yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
You can contest people if you want to Oh, I see yeah Why
there's no one contest us because they're scared of us.
I don't know why
why the fuck would they contest us when they know they're
gonna lose but we lost but if we lost oh jesus maria yeah
yeah okay we lost i get we get it we get it we lost you like
losing no that's why i want to because i was just fact
checking you fact this is really bad for the team morale
right now
i am lucy calm down up here calm down it's just a game come
i will find you
oh hey there's a havoc are they yeah yeah yeah there's two
avics i like how i want both both i'm a flatline 301 i will
shoot you that line for you one i need both amazing oh
prowler i want prowler actually i like prowler i'm i need
energy ammo there's a lot of energy on this area good hey
people are donating to me for your therapy funds just send
it over to my paypal i'll use it properly it's called
alcohol guys don't worry just uh i'm here to raise funds for
rpr's therapy it will go straight towards him if you donate
your super chest to me there's no therapy in life you just
drink it off you forget pio you didn't ping yeah ping what
ping what massive play meta why i want to use massive
I'm gonna go here with the beacon.
I am gonna grab a battery.
If you found vault, tell me.
Oh, I know where there's a vault.
There's energy here.
I saw a vault earlier.
I can't use a survey beacon because we're in white armor.
Okay, I have a scan.
Yeah, yeah, scan and then we can get per blue.
Pathfinder can't do shit until he gets it.
a blue armor useless you still need oh wait here there's a
gold one here does anyone want that up here dang it you want
that do what what do i want energy energy magazine yes yes i
like that great i'm here guys you i will drop a purple one i
will drop oh wait one team there It's a lot of people in a
storm catcher.
Okay.
You think it's...
Maybe we can go grab that one.
Yeah, go grab.
We need armor.
We're literally poor.
We're so poor.
Yes.
We need a wellness check.
I'm okay.
I'm going to go and grab.
I need therapy.
I'm going to help.
I got blue.
Yeah.
What do you need a blue for?
I don't speak to stupid.
If you have anything smart to say, I'll answer.
And none of these stupid's ever going to be answered.
But like a stupid person can get smarter by educating them.
They say no questions are dumb.
You proved it wrong just now
You're not teaching me anything so I'll stay stupid forever
Oh, you've been playing this game for five years But you've
been playing it professionally for five years You know what
Nah,
I refuse I refuse
where's the zone ending along with or without you i'm right
there what are you saying we're right behind you didn't you
didn't see me yeah how could you ignore dinner like that how
could you ignore her like that yeah what the fuck why wait
why do you guys close the door from me i'm sorry
She slammed the door in your face.
Do we need Alt-XL?
Nah.
I don't think we need Alt-XL.
We wait here for 12 seconds.
Okay.
Why should we go next?
Well, he said we gotta wait here for 12 seconds.
Okay.
Wait, you have that heirloom?
I just said it five seconds ago.
I just said it.
No, this is not just me!
I'm listening!
I literally listened.
Go back?
Okay.
I knew what was going on.
Great job, doggy.
Like, for once you listen.
Only took six games.
Five.
Oh, five.
There's someone on my left here.
These guys need to die.
Okay.
I got shot.
What the fuck?
I need a heal.
Wait, hold up.
I gotta go back.
I can hear.
I can see.
Come here.
I'm gonna ult them.
These motherfuckers are angry at us for no reason.
Now we gotta kill them.
They're gonna come inside now.
Are they?
I don't know.
I don't think they all did.
How much they have a death wish?
I'm worried but behind us too.
Why are they here?
Wait, I hit something.
Could they possibly be doing here?
Why am I lagging?
Yeah, you're lagging.
Yeah, yeah.
I see them.
They're outside.
Wait, no, they're not.
They're...
What the fuck are they, girl?
You hear that?
There was a vibration.
let's go why are you shooting at me bro where are they here
hit 100 conduit right here behind this she went inside the
house these guys need to die okay i think murder is about to
happen oh i shot fucking ditto i'm starting with this never
mind i can't do that they remove that fuck i can't go on the
on the They're redeploying.
I'm not gonna let them do that.
Uh, 30 on the Watson?
Conduit track!
Hello?
Ooh, careful.
I cracked...
I got cracked all of them.
All of them are cracked.
Oh, shit, you're right.
No, that's just two conduits.
Am I right?
Oh my god, it got stuck.
A conduit flesh, 115?
It's okay, it's okay.
Proof.
That bloodhound is sitting every wingman shot in the world.
I need a... I need a heal.
I'm getting a better spot I'm coming back I want these guys
dead That's a different team Chill here, chill here That's a
different team Okay You saved it here I'm gonna go back a
little bit I'm gonna be here Let this team knock them They
just knocked them Look at that evac Okay I'm looking There's
no way that person No way That's great That was crazy one
person took the that was actually that's only two here
people here we should fight them now okay okay there's only
two people where's his teammate though oh was did we get did
they get interpreted by one guy working i don't know i'm
gonna lift that package what is going on here i don't know
i'm looting yeah i am lagging so bad you are i hear it this
is why we're losing your voice is lagging a little you're
going robot really where are we going by the way zone i
don't have bat anymore oh here i got you i got two okay
thank you i think my internet is fucked oh no that's not
good how are you gonna kill everybody for us there was a
fucking storm today there's a i'm gonna replay oh yeah i
have a replay i'm looking behind us just in case oh my god
i'm lagging i'm gonna sue someone
oh my god this is on purpose they're doing this to show me
purpose every time this is like east coast servers so you
even have like the benefits too yeah i don't know why i'm
lagging i think it's like i told you there's a massive storm
today i'm not but i'm lagging in discord too I told you
there's a master stones they fucked something up now I'm
lagging oh no that's not good electricity in the airs
machine how science works let's go here okay we're right
behind you there's probably people in this house is right we
have reapply do you want to use it no yes three yeah but I
want to walk and see what's in front of us before we evac
into someone's face and die that wouldn't happen right nope
that never happens to anyone just like that one team that
landed on us didn't die when they landed on us yeah but that
was on purpose yeah they wanted to die yeah no they thought
they could kill us they blocked this door off that's weird
why would you blow like let us play too hang yeah i'm gonna
wash all of that oh they're evacuing on my left That's
murder time.
I don't think they're going to, like, come here.
Oh, there's a team above them, that's why.
Okay, I will watch our back.
God, I hate lagging.
It makes me, it makes my blood boil.
That guy's one.
Bro, how?
I hit 10.
He was not one.
You're going to fight?
Okay, he was 12.
Like, we won't be.
You're going to fight?
We're going to fight?
No, we're just poking.
We're just poking, poking, poking.
Oh, they're fighting down here.
rounds we go okay okay i watch it back one team dead i'm
heading over nice one i don't think we can anymore okay i'm
heading back my arm is up word champ smoked our backs where
are you where are you we're back i'm washing our back tell
me if you want to fight i will go there what the fuck i what
okay i want okay i want i want to wash our back anymore okay
if we got if we get the third I'm so don't blame me
You didn't even say to me that No I totally wasn't talking
the entire time I wasn't talking I was just imagining that
part Wait they have red army Kill these guys Red armor
cracked Close to me close to me I'm okay Right below me
right below me right below me This is my This is their all
their all I gotta pull back because they're so horny.
They're all, they're all, by the way.
I'm safe here.
Ditto, Ditto, Ditto!
Ditto's way up ahead!
Oh my gosh!
Left side, left side, I think.
Left side, left side, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, in a smoke.
How can he see through smoke?
Wait, what?
How is he seeing through smoke?
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
I might be dead.
He might push me.
He's pushing, he's pushing.
He thought you were gonna push.
like what is yeah he saw me through his own smoke i was like
what it's a classic controller bullshit they can do
everything so unbelievable is that same bingler it killed us
last game i thought i thought you were gonna fly so i push
and you you leave me that's true i got hit for 150 like we
want me to die but i'm i i came to you to call for you but
you leave me yeah i got i got shot i'm sorry i got shot like
what do you like what do i do oh my gosh guys maybe it's not
guys i don't know this team cop i don't know i think it's a
team comp issue okay i hear one more team comp issue i'm
going to tell me if we are going to fight or not fight okay
i feel like i was talking the entire time what we're doing
what what we're doing yeah i i listen i said we're gonna
third party this team while they were fighting and but you
but you you tell me that you're gonna poke them yes we poke
them together and then we when we find the right moment we
push them when they're fighting but but when when it when is
the right moment you didn't tell me when they're fighting
when they're fighting but when when but i said they were
fighting we have to say go now we have to fight what do you
want from me you're not listening it doesn't matter what i
say you're not gonna listen i'm listening i'm listening i'm
listening
just chill like um okay we fight everything i was doing like
what more can i do i can't i can't i'm gonna lose it i can't
i'm gonna give up
i'll play i'll play blood i'll play blood hand i won't wash
our back i won't i won't go with you
How is it always my fault?
It's just insane!
You are lagging.
You go now but go what go where?
Go now.
Go now?
Help me!
It's like, I know by the way you are supposed to do you.
You know!
Yes!
I'm sorry, but it's the timing.
What?
It's hard!
Where can I go?
Where?
Go now but go where?
I said come here they're fighting yeah I went I went to you
I went to you you were looking at the back yeah because that
there might be a third party you know third party we are
third party we we are third party we are third party we we
can be third party even if we third party you know come here
you have to go everyone come here i i thought i thought you
told you doggy you know because you you are you were with
doggy so i thought you were talking to doggy because i told
you that i was washing our bag so if you want to if you want
to have to tell my my phone from now on from now on i'm
going to tell everyone what to do at every given moment i'm
going to use your name i'm going to tell you come here this
guy push this guy and i'm gonna say donkey come here dito
come here dito push here dito push here dito throw nades
dito throw nades dito shoot that guy dito shoot that guy
dito res me dito throw me a drone like supposed to do thank
for you guys like i don't get it that's all we wanted that's
all we wanted no no just tell me just only tell me okay dito
we fight everyone we fight only this i i said i said we're
gonna poke these guys we as a our team one one two three
three people three people we don't we can refer to two
people like you and donkey can we be we as well why would i
say why would i say we if i don't if i meant only two people
we is the whole team it's you me and okay okay okay okay i
when you say we i will follow you okay yes perfect thank you
okay All right, we solved the problem.
We solved the problem.
I once watched our bag.
We just...
They'll be okay.
Okay.
Okay, listen.
It's really simple.
If I say we go here, then whole team go here.
If I say Dito watch back, then you watch back.
If I say Doki go right, then Doki goes right.
But if I say we, that means all three of us go somewhere.
Okay.
Easy?
Yeah.
I got it.
I understand.
Okay.
So...
Do you understand anything?
Doki?
Yeah.
I want to be Bloodhound.
Okay.
I will be bang on.
Yeah.
Again, we changing comp.
Because like we're figuring things out.
That's what you said.
why what what what do we what do we play i'm bloodhound it's
okay listen uh-huh listen this this is why screams exist so
we fix this problem you see we are fixing problems right now
okay okay why is my game trying to end itself what are what
do we're our problems yeah you because i just said me just
listening you're just starting shit all the time you're just
started arguments in the team 24 7.
i didn't even start anything this time you see deto is
confused and and and you're making me mad and then it's just
your fault on the of day like it's really like at the end of
day everything is your home we need a raven we need a coach
we don't need a fucking coach we need you to focus we need
tsm raven ducky for the five games we played you have been
focused for three minutes max i was so focused last game i
was with you the entire time that was 45 seconds that you
were focused yeah so it wasn't my fault this it's a nobody's
fault why does it have to be someone's fault
like why do we have to give the fault to someone why can't
we just die and he was like unlucky let's go next because
we're tsm that's what happened tsm we are low paying tsm
yeah tsm there's always somebody's fault in tsm i'm not
ready for tsm but we'll be famous we're gonna be on top i
want to go back to scars i want to go back to scars what do
you what okay i'm gonna go back to when things were easier
in life yeah guys we're eighth place guys what happened to
us we fell off why are you so focused on our placement you
just want to ruin our guys we're just like tsm you just want
to ruin our mood you're just trying to ruin this steam from
the inside it's an inside job no it's not i'm trying to
motivate us to do better you you you have to be calm down
okay when you are there i'm calm just be more cool be more
cool okay so what are this what do you want me to do how do
i get more calmer breathe it okay you breathe in count to
10.
it's like it's like it's like i have have this fucking devil
on my shoulder called donkey just trying to just like do you
don't dito do you not listen to what this dumbass is asking
me throughout the entire match why do you need blue armor
why do you need this why do you need that blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah why she's asking questions she's just
asking yeah why would i need blue armor why would i need
blue armor why why why would i need it why would i need it i
understand what was the important part about having blue
army why why why can you answer her properly he's just
asking she just wanted you no i was just curious i wanted to
expand my knowledge because you're igl and i look up to you
i look up to you so i wanted to know more yeah she didn't
know yeah how did she do how How did she not know this?
How did she not know?
Please tell me.
Please explain how this...
I was playing Tekken last week.
She hasn't been playing Apex World Y.
So in one week, she forgot what armor does in this video.
It happens sometimes.
Yeah, sometimes it happens.
Yeah.
I don't know if you're crazy like her or like you're fucking
with me right now.
Team Severe Monero.
With TSM.
I'm lacking in the air This is insane How many things you
have One AD One AD is not that laggy Yeah but I'm also like
lost I have lots Oh like everyone is Trey pointing Yes It's
the same shit They're de-hosting me Because we won the first
game Yeah we peaked early guys Just like TSM won the first
game i've been lagging coincidence i don't think so yeah we
should like ddos the other teams yes okay i i went playing
massive i i was not playing massive oh hey there's a bug i
like bug oh i'm gonna do repeater actually i should do
nemesis no actually no i want carbine
14 years of my life.
You.
Me?
I didn't argue with you this time.
You made me get into an argument with Dita, which took 14
years of my life.
What did I do to that argument?
You instigate all the time.
I did not instigate this time.
I literally was just chilling.
I was minding my own business listening in.
I have...
Let me...
okay but we learned we learned we learned something today we
learned yeah we means us yeah you means you and me means
means me wait who's you where's you yeah oh yeah me or ditto
yes exactly so if i say you doki or you ditto that means i'm
talking to you oh okay yeah i gotta understand okay see look
we're fixing a communication problem before the tournament
yeah basic english it is now done now we can move on yeah
yeah finally i am lagging so much it's insane i can't do
anything tell them to pause the game like algs so you can
fix your internet no this is this is a planned attack from
the inside they're dedocing me dedoc them back hit up
destroyer okay yeah we're best friend of me and destroyer
yeah do you guys not know that chat rpr actually knows
destroyer yeah we'll just we hang out and like what's his
name tuffy yeah tuffy best buddy tuffy's eu right tuffy's a
fucking idiot that's what he is all right do i want the
raven's charges ultimate or double the duration uh duration
of scan is more important okay when you scan people you can
where do we go i want a sentinel where do we go we don't we
have zone okay there's no reason for us to go oh okay zero
tell you that yes zero i can't yeah i don't mean listen to
zero yeah yeah this is not even me this is zero making all
this is he like call wait can zero be our can't zero be a
raven no i know i actually have a i actually have a
tournament this saturday right before we play i have to play
with zero and hardeki yeah so like why can't zero coach us
because he doesn't care he would care if you say why would
he care because he's your friend okay and so friends should
look out for each other is now what friendship is about
about that's what they tell you in the kindergarten in real
life you realize your friendship is all about people having
a use out of you the best way they can utilize you and once
once they do no longer have a use for you you're no longer
friends wait but then like then why can't we use zero
because he's busy you know that he was free to play that you
don't know that you don't know that you
wait oh he's like a champion he's busy no he's your friends
with benefits no what the fuck are you on about that's what
you said is that what it meant no that's not what it meant
it meant that like uh you're only friends with people while
you're interesting to them once you stop being interested in
them they move on just like everyone in life and then you
just lose friends and you keep cycling them because people
move on there's people in front of us fuck are they gonna
move on oh game goal they're like on this so they might take
that okay oh yeah wait they're looking at us why why do you
guys look at it 105 105 I got shot wait that blood okay wait
what the fuck is that guy doing I can't 63 flesh 63 last guy
last guy one hp let's reload i have to reload why are they
smoking vape nation flashed one flight oh no they're so
lucky oh i need g ace there's nobody behind what if i zip on
the roof and we just go all out this is our last game
exactly we got balls deep oh yeah i shouldn't do that
they're watching they're watching yeah i don't know we
should yeah but we we bait them with the zip line then i get
an angle headshot someone for 175 to the head and then we
just destroy them okay we're waiting for the destroy i'm
charging my sentinel i need to go behind us yeah there's a
redeploy behind us 88 88 why do they have purple they just
had blue now they have purple no they avoid that purple
There's people behind us redeploying, by the way.
Yeah, people behind us are almost dead.
Give me that head.
Give me the head.
What do we do?
Waiting for this team to, like, make a mistake and then
murder them.
Oh, what if they don't make a mistake?
They will.
They always make mistakes.
Okay.
Fucking cheater.
You call everyone cheater.
if he dies he dies to a cheater oh my god i can see i can't
see through the wall wait this guy blue you can see through
the hole and shoot them yeah shoot them where is that what's
that oh my god oh my lag what's that can we shoot it do it
88 purple crack i need a tear who's next who's next i'm
scared come on guys speak again come on oh my god this like
is insane i'm gonna go see there's extra shield cells oh
he's shooting me from to the wall are they shooting no
there's a gap in that there's a gap in them ben oh he's a
fan kick out of the tournament oh right 88 crack bangalore
i'm going to juice all of their meds until they cannot met
anymore i need to find more shield cells i'm gonna go back
and explore okay i can i can give it to you here oh nice
there was no Please do not explore the afterlife.
They stop.
They stop peeking.
All right.
In 10%, I'm going to give us a zip that's going to go there.
Should we go near you?
Yeah, sure.
10%.
Yeah, go here.
We're here.
2%, 1%.
Okay.
You first.
We want to get ahead of them and why are they smoking?
Rape Nation again.
Where are they shooting at us?
I don't know, but we want to get ahead of them and take
control of the positioning and then gatekeep them out of the
fucking zone.
So we're gonna get...
Looking behind us.
We're gonna...
I don't think anyone's gonna talk from behind us.
There is.
I don't think they're gonna come to us.
Are they coming?
They're on the bridge.
Like the...
The bridge behind us.
Or the left bridge?
Yeah, see the lifeline package?
Oh yeah.
Yeah, but there's two T's there.
Do I head to you?
You guys can ...
Someone can stay on the bridge there Okay, I'll stay I just
want to these guys not to come here I don't want them to
fucking come to us They're raising, they're raising behind
us Oh, they are raising Yeah, yeah, they're raising It is a
mobbie I thought it was Well, I'm gonna stay here then Well,
that guy's gonna one of them is gonna be broke Here I'm
looking I will stay with doggy Yeah, you can stay with doggy
I can grapple back I'm gonna scan What?
flag yeah i'm pulling the out of this team who shot you over
here over there one pink i'll deal with them later right now
i'm dealing with this team there's a team underneath that
bridge okay i'm gonna go to you don't get me yeah oh they
have to be ready this team might push me in the in the cave
too because they yeah that's fine they're not gonna deal
with us we just just be ready to get if i get pushed here be
ready to like fight this team i'm looking at the team in the
cave are they teaming fucking cheaters this these guys have
to move so now now be ready to get closer to me be ready
this team might push i'm gonna come over now i'm here yeah
just stay on that side of the bridge and then these guys i
mean we can even play from here all of us we just want these
guys to off all right go through the tunnel get here over
there once you know there on on our Is it three people?
Yeah, two people.
Yeah, I see them they're crossing.
Yeah, yeah, they're going around.
Yeah.
We just want to keep that in this.
Yeah, these guys are coming out.
They're jumping out.
They're going to the tunnel, I think.
No, they're pushing me.
They're pushing me.
Come here, come here, come here.
We're looking for you.
I smoked.
They smoked as well.
Yeah, we killed these guys.
We have to.
Yeah, no choice.
Use blood.
Use bonan ult.
I'm gonna use my ult.
Oh, they're close.
Yeah, I scan one of them.
Oh, they need it!
Fine.
You can pull back to the backside.
I need a heal.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Just play in the middle of the bridge, right here.
One guy, one, one guy hit my ult.
Is that your ult?
I will climb up.
I'm surrendering.
Oh, they're fighting.
They're fighting each other over there.
I can scan in one I'm scanning I'm scanning I didn't protect
anyone but I see a another cannon another cannon another
cannon they're crossing the crossing the crossing blue armor
I can't hit him because of this fucking lag I'm lagging like
a bitch it's still over there behind this rock yeah that
team is like whatever oh my god they're just helping that
thing is literally just helping us my arrow is not that much
what do you need yeah try to try to save energy oh i can
give you one i can give you some okay i have 180 right now i
have three but i'm running out of i'm running low on sniper
armor i got purple whoa these are still here but yeah i
would hit them if i wasn't if they weren't teleporting i
don't know where they're going They're smoking you.
Oh wait, wait.
They might go from right side?
No, I see right side.
I see right side.
There's a guy crawling dead.
What?
He thirsts him?
Yeah, I thirsted a guy crawling in the water.
What the fuck was he doing there?
They're still there.
Yeah, my scan doesn't reach them.
Is this just a duo now?
I'm not sure.
I saw three over there.
What was this guy crawling towards?
How much cake on Bangalore?
Still there.
Yeah, they're just chilling.
them i i don't reach it like can you get a little bit closer
and oh how just a little bit like to this raw or something
yeah i can scan here i'll scan it but i'm still not close
enough oh it didn't unleash it yeah it didn't reach there's
a purple guy i think that's a new castle you gotta go Take,
take, take on Kanji.
Okay, okay.
Let me think about zone.
You guys still holding there.
I can give you guys a zip when it's time to move.
Okay, that's in.
This is in.
Yeah, they're close to us right now.
I'm backing up to you.
Yeah, they're pushing, they're pushing, they're pushing,
they're pushing.
It's okay.
We play from here and we hold them back.
I can, let me know when to scan.
95 headshot on Newcastle.
They're gonna go here and they're gonna play those rocks.
We have to keep this rock.
Okay, nobody turn.
This is so laggy, I'm so annoyed.
Be careful, Owen.
Yeah, those guys behind us can't see us.
They smoke this.
They're going to cross now.
These guys are going to cross.
We need to scan them.
I have 11 seconds.
Scanning like this direction, like left side.
Seven.
There's a team in that cave I'm looking at.
I can see I know one.
Where are these guys?
Okay, they can go.
They crossed.
One guy.
There, there's a shot from here.
Oh my god.
They know, careful, careful.
They're over here on the side.
They're shooting from left.
Just play on me.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
They might push now.
They're gonna push us.
Okay, they're beaming me.
Yeah, I'm getting beam from the other side too.
It's not good here.
We can like...
There's just no one alive in this fucking lobby.
So they can just do whatever the fuck they want.
They're hard pushing.
Yeah.
I'm lagging way too much, bro.
Everyone's teleporting.
Yes, great.
That's fine.
Okay.
It's just a squim.
You we had lagged debuff.
We had lag debuff.
I'm literally getting fucking dedost.
I'm getting dedost.
This is insane.
How did...
I was fine the entire time and then all of a sudden
everyone's teleporting.
How is this rigging?
this can't be real i think i think we need wraith okay now
we need wraith again wow i don't know i feel like i feel
like pathfinder just wasn't the right pick
so it's always the comps fault it's not is there anything
else well if we had wraith we could have portal to a safer
area I picked rage.
We're like, we had power and we could have zipped on high
ground.
Or if we had this, we could have done that.
If we made it, yeah.
Yeah, this is the last game.
Yeah, it was OG.
Yeah, it's six games.
Is it?
It should be.
It's like a squirm.
This is the last game.
It's okay, guys.
We were just, we didn't show them our true strength.
Honestly, if I wasn't lagging right there, I would have
killed that fucking team all of us crossing i had so many
free shots i couldn't hit because they're teleporting what
if you all right if you like um on the tournament yeah what
are you like on the tournament then we're just gonna lose i
don't know what to tell you but like why don't you just fix
your internet but how how how would i do that if you know
how please let me know because i'm somebody's house i'm not
gonna what whose house am i going to go to bring your pc
over to somebody's house that has good internet no one has
good internet here then how do you play i don't i don't play
apex because this listen this game has the worst net code on
the planet that's not true like super smash that is true me
and mande literally had year in this game just because apex
everything else works perfectly fine but apex is a 30
permanent packet loss it's only me and mandy no one else
well if it's just you two and there's a whole eu market but
only you two have issues in eu versus like 80 other eu
players then obviously it wasn't just us a lot of people lag
in rank and like but it's like specifically it's
specifically Like, certain ISPs just don't work with this
game because, I don't know, fuck them, my guys.
Wouldn't it be the ISP's fault?
So, so, if I did, okay, let me tell, let me, if the ISP
works in every single fucking game, but it doesn't work in
one game, is it really ISP's fault or the game's fucking
bullshit as a netcode?
Maybe the ISP didn't update for Apex because it was too new.
They don't need to update for no fucking game.
The game needs to update its netcode for the ISPs.
but why how come the other isp is away because jesus christ
i don't fucking know what look like a specialist
it's okay guys this is just a skirm guys we will yeah and
the tournament will do so it's okay no your internet will be
good yeah your internet will be good on the tournament
tournament I'm yeah just a bad day yeah I'm gonna run a twit
longer if I get DDoS some tournament it's going to be
addressed to everyone in this tournament fuck you
motherfuckers for DDoS to me fuck you every single one of
you hide us to ban them all I don't know which one it is but
one of you motherfuckers do it's you motherfucker just keep
shooting all your shots and eventually you'll hit yeah if i
just fucking blame everyone someone's not exactly exactly
take a book i'm gonna take a page from donkey's book you
blame everyone i'd do so i had a great time guys yeah it was
just great i like winning that one game yeah yeah that was
such a good game remember that time when we won that one
game i didn't like when you cosplay a statue that was not
very cool that was the last time rpr had good internet uh it
had to be i also didn't like when you were instigating
fights in the team how did i instigate i didn't even
instigate jack i was just asking questions yeah all i'm
gonna say is what you're on one someone's gonna listen why
why are we even arguing someone's gonna fucking clip there's
gonna be a fucking youtube clip dokey making rpr lose his
mind for the 57 time it's all fucking instigation bullshit
while we're playing screams and i'm trying my ass off while
you're we're trying our asses up yep yep yep why did you do
that why this why this why this why blah blah blah blah blah
blah why are we not winning i mean it is a good question two
questions allowed done.
I'm banning questions.
Then we'll never learn.
You don't need to learn.
You need to follow.
It's not about learning.
It's about following.
You guys, I had a great time.
I had a great time too.
yeah i can't wait for saturday when we have an even better
time yeah yeah i'm so excited guys yeah me too i can't wait
to play with rpr on saturday positive mental attitude i am
so yeah tsm tsm today it says a scream we don't take stairs
yeah scrims are nothing who cares about scrims you know yeah
i mean Look at our rod.
None of us were serious at all.
Yeah, none of us were serious.
Especially Doki.
No one cares about scrims, guys.
What?
But I told you, we win the first one and then we lose all
the other ones.
We make them think like they have something going on.
And then we fuck them on a German day.
Yeah, I agree.
Chichis everybody.
I had a great time.
did you have fun strat didn't you have fun it was great fun
guys that's great to know great stuff see RPR had a lot of
fun guys anyway if you want to donate to RPR's therapy fund
you can super chat to me and I'll make sure the money goes
to him guys make sure it comes in the form of a gin and
tonic or I am not accepting your donation well you don't
have to accept the donation but i'll accept it yeah yeah
farm me some more yeah yeah keep farming me yeah that's what
that's what you said that's what friend why is deto laughing
it's funny yeah it is funny she's right my suffering is
always funny this is great yeah we all suffer together
because it's friendship No, we did not suffer together.
I suffered and you guys laughed.
We did suffer together.
Yeah.
We all suffered together.
I suffered because we didn't win.
We didn't win.
That's suffering.
Not winning.
I suffered mental damage.
Yeah, I had mental damage from losing.
Yeah, we have mental damage from getting blaming by up here.
Yeah, we suffered mental damage because our peer blamed us.
okay hold up first and foremost i was not even the one
blaming what would happen is you guys wanted to blame like
when i was being chill and i was saying oh guys let's just
focus on winning why why do we have to blame people you guys
keep blaming everyone why did you do that why is this gone
whatever that what are you gonna you another blame nation
but we're tsm that's what it's We were just asking.
Yeah, we're asking too.
Not braiming, not braiming.
Yeah, we're just asking questions because we want to get
better.
And the hair gaslighting, I'm going to leave this column
before I leave my life.
Maybe you are too sleepy up here.
You are too sleepy to play this game.
It's okay.
You too?
This is like being stabbed in the back by your own daughter.
No!
I didn't do anything.
yeah we didn't do anything yeah yeah i always say yes i
always say um say to my shadow um let's pick up here because
yeah he's a hero second to zero she's just lying i watch
your stream all the time you never fucking said it i
literally watched you the other day i watched her the other
day friend and the entire time she was talking about me she
was talking about how scary i am and how a part of a person
i am no i'm not i watched her and she told and like on her
stream like last week she was saying how much she admired
you and how you're like you're like her hero yeah yeah i say
it's a hero yeah it was on her last stream she streams so
much i don't remember she streams a lot but i saw it do you
remember that time when she talked about like how much she
admires rpr did those chat see the chat agrees hey dito's
chat hey show me the chat agrees well they're not going to
be able to find a clip right away it was so long ago it was
like last week yeah yeah uh do you realize that the dito's
title is literally scream with doki and one rpr no it's not
no i don't see that there's someone who respects someone
really right one stupid what does it say that where refresh
your refresh your um my hero i have screenshots i have
screenshots i have screenshots too i have screenshots You
have Photoshop.
That's not fair.
That's not Photoshop.
What do you mean?
Yeah.
And now you're like gaslighting all of us.
Wait, wait.
One stupid up here.
No, no.
One hero.
Yeah, it says.
Your title is literally RPR will die first.
No, no, it's not.
Where did you see that?
I don't understand.
it says rpr will not die first i'm gonna go to bed i'm gonna
go to bed i'm gonna go to bed literally rpr will not die
first and ditto is like and one hero rpr i i'm gonna i'm
gonna go to bed and i got homework for you guys you guys
should really reconsider your choices tonight like really
consider the words you're saying to me really think about it
next time we play really think about which words you're
saying to me and what kind of damage effect they could have
on my mental health going forward and that's what i'm gonna
leave you with for tonight thank you guys for watching
goodbye ggs thanks everybody bye-bye everyone and goodbye
bye-bye ending screen now